these rivers and wetlands around Dhaka
are clogging up and drying out once a
Lifeline for millions of people in the
capital of Bangladesh they've Fallen
victim to Rapid economic growth and
Decades of uncontrolled development and
industrialization
Muhammad Rahman is one of many farmers
who have turned to underground water to
keep their business alive
river is badly polluted due to chemical
discharge from garments and dying
Factory we can't use this water there is
hardly any fish in the river crops
barely grow here and we are facing much
hardship the department of environment
has declined all the rivers around taka
City biologically dead the Bangladesh
High Court in 2019 declared All Rivers
as living entities observing that the
country will survive if the rivers are
protected around environmentalist
Muhammad Azad says industrial pollution
untreated sewage and urban expansion are
destroying ecosystems around the city
all the species in the water and the
water bodies and the wetlands these are
all dead so the impact of this critical
EC ecologically critical rivers are very
very bad
to these City people as well as the
community who are living along this
River
according to a study by the World Bank
1.5 million cubic meters of Wastewater
from 7 000 industrial units enters four
major rivers near Dhaka every day
in the asholia area most of the garments
and dying factories discharge their
Wastewater without treatment as required
by law and pollute this entire area
killing all Greenery around here experts
say a failure to enforce laws on waste
and inefficient management are the main
reasons for the high level of water
pollution now the country has a law by
which each industry must treat the water
through an ETP effluent treatment plant
but unfortunately it is not obeyed now
government is seeking help from World
Bank and a major project is coming up
soon
ah how to control it how to treat it Al
jazeera's request for an interview with
chairman of the Bangladesh national
River Conservation Commission was
declined Global demand for relatively
cheap clothes and other consumer goods
from Bangladesh remains high but those
whose livelihoods depends on its
waterways and rivers so they are the
ones paying the price Chandra chaudry Al
Jazeera Australia Dhaka